c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le loiret
qui gagnent des habitants en dix ans le
département a gagné 29 mille loire est
un supplémentaire
nous sommes aujourd'hui 674 1330
première commune de la liste évidemment
orléans avec 114 1780 deux habitants
viennent ensuite olivier 21 1520 et
fleury-les-aubrais en troisième position
avec 20 1973 habitants autres
départements de la région centre qui
voit sa population augmenter doucement
mais sûrement l'indre et loire avec
douze mille âmes supplémentaires
principal bénéficiaire la ville de tours
mais surtout sa couronne
pas de surprise concernant le berry se
dépeuple temps dans le cher où la
population a baissé de 0,13 % que dans
l'indre diminution de 0,6 pour cent soit
un déficit de six mille six cent
soixante dix habitants en cinq ans la
seule ville de châteauroux aura perdu
1433 habitants du côté du loir et cher
c'est une surprise le département rural
augmente légèrement ses habitants ils en
gagnent 1489 avec des disparités
territoriales cependant blois et vendôme
perdre des habitants quand la ville de
romorantin en gagne légèrement avec 1038
personnes supplémentaires enfin
l'eure-et-loir s'en sort plutôt bien
avec une hausse de 3500 très habitants
c'est le troisième département le plus
peuplé de la région centre et cidre
gagne des habitants l'agglomération
chartraine se dépeuple peu à peu en cinq
ans la ville de chartres a perdu 521
habitants